runde alles oder nichts naja wenn ich
gewinne dann habe ich gewonnen hast du
gewinnst machen alles noch mal richtig
spannend entscheidende sprung
nein nein
besonders willkommen zu einer runde
superjob heute mit dem trainer kay
dennis i ha ha ha ha du kannst dich
wunderschön ausdrücken superjet anke und
zwar habe ich mal sagen würde ich mal
sagen starten einfach mit einer schönen
chilligen map stehen wir spielen best of
three
das heißt wer als erster wir spielen
einfach weil das deutsche spiel gewöhnt
hat
ich weiß das nicht
ich kann das nicht benennen was ich name
von der sache
the game okay und es ist mitten in der
nacht leute ein uhr morgens immer noch
halb voll produzieren für den dividende
hat eben zwei stunden versuchte mich so
was auch zu den bisher gemerkt haben
okay zweifel gab es bis heute nicht
ich bin so behindert und wird sich
springer einfach gegen den scheiß
dagegen versucht einfach den block so
bis zu überreden sein spiel gegen den
kommerz und kopfpolster lass mich drauf
ist nein ich bin der größte
horst schlämmer der welt alter a/s
wahrung ich dass ich war schon auf dem
fall darauf dem fahrradfahrer gesagt ein
verlusten bogen
grassmann bis beide augen gerade ein
kopf an kopf an kopf
nein das tut immer so weh also die
lustigsten schmerzhaftesten peinlichsten
fails gerade nachts um eins wenn er so
gar nichts mehr geht dann geht es immer
richtig ab jetzt richtig runter ich bin
doch ohne wieder dagegen gesprungen
meine versuche
nein
was fühlt sich immer so gut an wenn du
einfach verkackt wenn ich verkackt fühlt
sich für dich gut an
ich bin also ihr könnt jetzt nicht auf
diese idee kam ihr dann sage ich
anspringen im dritten block ins fucking
what
ich bin ein scheiße also von daher
wunderbar sagt man das ist bei mir super
job ist bei mir schon älter aber sowas
von verzweiflung manchmal lacht manchmal
weinen
ich kenne ja auch mal so eine halben
orgasmus verschenken jump schaffe sie
erzählt was er danke liebe leute danke
danke danke okay jetzt kommt michael
stich erster von 313 geht so ist gemacht
wie schaffe ich dich einladen wir machen
einfach mal abwechslung so die unten auf
der bank aber kennst du das wenn du so
zu den zu den dingen schafft den sprung
und dann so richtig so ein richtiges
glücksgefühl hast ja das ist also bei
mir ist immer so denkst du bekommst du
landest du da ist so ein gefühl der
erleichterte
gleich verteilt die panther-fans ja also
oft ja aber keine hausmacht hinter kam
jetzt kam ja dann hat mich ein
je nachdem wie lange es dauert machen
die fläche waren fünf oder was können
wir machen
safenet es ist mir egal es kann nicht ok
ok haben wir auch glaube ich schon mal
zusammen gezuckt meine ich ja ich glaube
auch dadurch ist es war so eine folge
hatte ich so eine ganz witzige audiospur
was im ja genau die mit dem es nicht die
beste folge vor einem burnout
geilomat ico war nicht mal fünf sekunden
der mädchen runtergefallen ja kaum einen
stich soll stehe ich jetzt bräuchte ich
ja die gibt's den behinderungen eisbär
wieso er so bachmann hatte nein zeigt
mich hier von meiner scale seite auf
jeden fall wo man ein
das geht doch nicht dass da nichts geht
doch nicht klar weil man ein bisserl
gewisse leute verlieren die ist doch
nicht mitbekommen wenn dieses video
online kommt sind wir auf dem d day in
berlin ein treffen ganz viele youtube
aus dem dvv netzwerk in dem ich auch bin
das sind da max ist da es wird rot pilze
wie für andere sachen lebewesen menschen
so kommen jetzt bitte nicht dein ernst
ich bin so dumm und dafür muss ich vor
produzieren ist kann die sein
wenn dein leben in den kopf wenn nicht
dann halt deine schnauze
doch michael so scheiße wenn du dann
fahr doch weg wenn du das willst mit
mist mist
schick mir ist jetzt richtig auf alta
vista chip ist
ich bin wahrscheinlich leuten ein jedes
mal selbst ist richtig tricky richtig
brutal da ich bin so brutus brutalos
alte jahr lichterfeld nord bis ich
fertig bin bewusst du nur ein co-pilot
naja die keine ahnung warum
wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt wohne ist
die sache vorbei
ja denn wenn ich dumm und springt
einfach zu weit
falls du willst und sonst ein ganz
normaler kerl er sein leben jetzt
konzentration ok alles konzentriert ich
konzentrier dich das ist jetzt final jam
wenn du durch gewonnen hat stand ganz
oben auf und filmte das kann doch nicht
sein alter ist kann nicht sein auf
werden
mir macht es einfach com 21
danke liga del gewonnen
du hast nicht gewohnt groß doch ab
gewann nicht riska warnen jetzt okay
manchmal darunter alles oder nichts naja
wenn ich gewinne dann habe ich gewonnen
hier gewinnen aber nur mit einer die
auch kurz und knapp ist kennst du ja
sehr gut sehr gut das feierlich das ist
lang da ich mich an ob sie an einig
escape exakt wir kennen beide wohl
gefreut gern wahr denn vanessa kennt sie
ja kennen fans dieser sportart ein wenig
dicker jetzt doch das interesse einzige
der erste der bei einem best of 3 3 nur
noch gewinnen kann rückstand ja ja
gewiss nicht ja ja nein ich habe mir
nichts zuschulden kommen lassen ok ich
hoffe nur das sind jetzt fliege
wiedergeboren werde im nächsten leben
entgegen kammer wenn nicht sogar
arbeitsmarkt bis schon wieder da hinten
nein da muss ich weiter aus dem block da
muss ich aber weiter raus ist das
rätsels lösung einfach weiter rausgehen
nach rechts da verkürzt sich die
entfernung ähnlich alter w
würde es nochmal richtig spannend
entscheidende sprung
nein nein nein nein
es dreht sich fast nicht leute warum
rein oder einfach meine fresse deutsche
tennis aber dessen der beschreibung wenn
euch die folge gefallen hat dann lassen
wir die nach oben da oder einen
dominiert dem welches geschlecht ihr
bevorzugt schreibt mir in die kommentare
falls irgendwelche anmerkung habe falls
ihr mehr superchamp versehen
oder doch mehr nackt videos ist kein
ding einfach in die kommentare damit
natürlich sagen sind zunächst wieder
wieder drei macht's gut und